Movies are a visual medium, and therefore,
most movies' major characters are, well, visible
to the audience.
But as with any rule, there are notable exceptions
— and to prove it, these are just a few
memorable examples of film characters you
never see.
Thanks to the success of the original Charlie's
Angels television series, which ran from 1976
to 1981, a film reboot was inevitable; in
2000, director McG's adaptation, which starred
Cameron Diaz, Drew Barrymore, and Lucy Liu,
hit theaters.
As the titular team working out of an exclusive
agency in Los Angeles, the trio lend the film
the feel of the original television series
while setting it in a more modern era and
stretching one mystery into a longer story.
As in the original series, Charlie is perpetually
unseen, accessible only through speaker and
identified only as the Angels' millionaire
boss who finds them different jobs, gives
them instructions, and works through his assistant
Bosley.
Though the film never addresses why Charlie
isn't present, aside from indicating that
he's frequently targeted by villains and assassins,
the closing scene shows a man quietly observing
the angels, who could be Charlie himself though
he still remains obscured to the viewer.
How will we ever know you really, truly exist
unless you come down here and have a coconut
with us?"
"Faith, angels.
It's called faith."
Spike Jonze is known for his inventive, ambitious
projects, and 2013's Her, which won Best Original
Screenplay at the 86th Academy Awards as well
as scoring a nomination for Best Picture tackles
the concept of artificial intelligence from
an entirely new perspective.
Set just slightly ahead of the present day,
the film imagines a time when humans are able
to create virtual assistants using artificial
intelligence.
Theodore played by Joaquin Phoenix feels disconnected
from the people around him after a rough divorce…
until he meets Samantha.
"I can understand how the limited perspective
of an un-artificial mind would perceive it
that way.
You'll get used to it."
As Theodore gets closer to his AI assistant
Samantha seductively voiced by Scarlett Johansson
he realizes that their relationship isn't
as special as he previously thought.
She admits that she's in similar "relationships"
and in love with hundreds of other people
before telling him that she and the other
AIs are leaving the human sphere.
As society creeps closer to the advent of
new forms of artificial intelligence, the
unseen assistants of Her become even more
relevant, warning audiences about the benefits
and costs of technology that may soon become
a reality.
Adapted from Ira Levin's novel, Roman Polanski's
horror classic Rosemary's Baby stars Mia Farrow
as Rosemary, a woman who believes a Satanic
cult wants to use her baby for evil purposes.
When Rosemary and her husband Guy move into
their new apartment in New York City, they
befriend an odd elderly couple who welcome
the young pair with open arms.
However, throughout the film, Rosemary becomes
suspicious of them, and as she experiences
a truly horrific pregnancy, she realizes that
her child is not her husband's, but actually
the son of the Devil, and she must raise the
child as her own to appease this dangerous
cult.
"Read what they do, Guy!
They use blood in their rituals, and the blood
that has the most power is baby's blood."
During the film's finale, Rosemary discovers
that her child is the son of Satan, who "chose"
her to carry his baby, and rather than show
the baby directly, there's simply a flash
of a demonic face perhaps the child's father,
Satan.
"What have you done to its eyes?"
"He has his father's eyes."
In refusing to show an actual shot of the
child, the film leaves its appearance up to
the imagination, making it even more frightening
than, say, a potentially unrealistic prosthetic
"demon" baby.
The second film in the long-running Ernest
film series, Ernest Saves Christmas features
Jim Varney's character Ernest and serves as
the holiday-themed installment in the franchise.
Ernest, who appeared in several commercials
for brands like Coca-Cola and and Chex, made
his mark by always delivering an impassioned,
off-topic monologue to his friend Vern while
speaking directly to the camera, which always
culminated in him proclaiming the virtues
of whatever product he happened to be pitching.
"Got 'im, Vern.
Another Pacific Pilsner.
That's a keeper!"
In Ernest Saves Christmas , Ernest, a taxi
driver working in Florida, inadvertently picks
up Santa Claus and accidentally gains possession
of Santa's magic sack of toys.
Through a series of misadventures, he helps
find the next man who will become Santa Claus
and makes sure Christmas goes smoothly and
also throughout the film, he delivers his
trademark monologues to Vern, whose POV is
once again provided by the camera.
During one notable scene, he even helps host
a Christmas party at Vern's house, much to
Vern's apparent chagrin.
"Ho, ho, ho, Vern!
Merr—"
"I thought you said this Vern was a friend
of yours."
"D'oh, Vern's just like that: He'll do anything
for a laugh."
OK, so chances are you already know the whole
story of Romeo and Juliet —
"From forth the fatal loins of these two foes,
a pair of star-crossed lovers take their life."
but, in case you've been living under a rock,
here goes: Romeo and Juliet, respective heirs
to the warring Montague and Capulet families,
meet by chance at a party and immediately
fall in love, even though they're conditioned
to hate one other and even though Juliet is
already engaged to someone else.
Though they do their best to make a new life
together, their plans are foiled at every
turn, and they eventually do the whole poison/dagger
thing, and yada yada yada.
You know how this one turns out.
"Poison!
I'll kiss thy lips.
Haply some poison doth yet hang on them."
Aw, crap wrong movie.
Hold tight.
The play has seen plenty of adaptations over
the years, but the most popular among modern
viewers is Baz Luhrman's fantastical Romeo
+ Juliet, which modernizes the sets and costumes
while retaining the original prose.
It's pretty weird, and it shouldn't work — but,
honestly, somehow it does.
They have made worms' meat of me.
A plague on both your houses!"
Though most know the narrative outline, it's
easy to forget that Juliet isn't always the
only girl on Romeo's mind in fact, when the
story begins, Romeo is heartsick over another
girl, Rosaline, who seemingly won't give him
the time of day.
When his friend Mercutio encourages him to
attend Juliet's party so he can forget about
Rosaline, Romeo's former love is forgotten
and, in fact, never appears in the play or
film at all.
Still, she plays a relatively important part
in the whole tragic mess: If she hadn't left
Romeo heartbroken, he may never have even
met Juliet!
2010's Winter's Bone introduced Jennifer Lawrence
to mainstream film audiences.
Set in the Ozarks, this low-budget drama stars
Lawrence as Ree, who is solely responsible
for taking care of her mentally ill mother
as well as her two younger siblings.
While she attempts to teach her siblings how
to survive, she's also tasked with finding
her father, who has disappeared after his
arrest for making meth, and the stakes are
high if she doesn't find him in time, then
her family's house and land will be seized,
leaving them with a week to find somewhere
else to live.
Along the way, she runs afoul of the town's
crime boss, Milton, while everyone tells her
that her father is already dead, and she tries
to figure out what the real story is even
as bondsmen hunt him down.
"Some of our blood at least is the same, ain't
that supposed to mean something?
Isn't that what is always said?"
As it turns out, everyone is right her father
is, in fact, dead, as Ree discovers when the
Milton clan shows her his body partially submerged
in a lake.
Left with only his hands to identify him to
the sheriff and bondsmen, Ree's journey is
over and she can be at peace, but her unseen
father's character remains vital to the story,
as searching for him to save her family is
what drives her throughout the entire narrative.
The 1964 classic Dr. Strangelove or: How I
Learned to Stop Worrying and Love the Bomb
sprung from the mind of legendary director
Stanley Kubrick.
This dark comedy focused on a Cold War era
nuclear conflict between the United States
and the Soviet Union.
Starring legends Peter Sellers and George
C. Scott, the film's central conflict hinges
upon a deranged general who orders a nuclear
strike by the United States against the Soviet
Union and the efforts of the United States
President and his cabinet to then try to stop
the strike.
Though this might not sound like a laugh riot,
the script and Sellers' multiple performances
are so hilarious that the film has become
known as one of cinema's best comedies, earning
itself a place in the National Film Registry
and the third spot on the 100 Years 100 Laughs
list at AFI.
"Gentlemen, you can't fight in here — this
is the war room!"
Because the film centers on a conflict between
the U.S. and Soviet Union, one might think
the Russian premier would be fairly central,
but thanks to the focus on the United States
government's response, Premier Dmitri Kissoff
is ultimately never seen, providing most of
the film's push and pull without ever having
to physically appear on screen and existing
only through phone calls to and from the President.
"Uh, we're doing a documentary about the Blair
Witch."
"Oh."
"Oh, have you heard of the Blair Witch?"
"Oh yeah, that's an old, old, old story."
One of the first forays into the modern era
of the "found footage" subgenre of horror
films, The Blair Witch Project was filmed
over only eight days, stranding actors in
the woods with handheld equipment to lend
an air of authenticity to the frightening
story.
"I'm not playing head games, man.
If anyone's playing head games, you're playing
head games, but I'm not playing head games."
In fact, the viral marketing campaign was
almost too successful, including the decision
to keep the actors from attending the film's
premiere and listing them as deceased on IMDb.
The production was a real-life horror in its
own right; the actors were intentionally deprived
of food and pranked by the crew to elicit
"real" reactions for the final product.
"HEEEELP!
HEEEELP!
PLEASE HELP US!
HELP US!"
In the low-budget/high-scares flick, a group
of amateur filmmakers Heather, Mike, and Josh
document their search for the mysterious Blair
Witch.
Though they're initially skeptical of any
supernatural phenomena, during their time
in the woods, they're tormented by some unseen
force.
When Josh goes missing, it appears as if the
Blair Witch herself is mimicking his screams
to lure Heather and Mike.
After they find an abandoned house, Mike's
camera footage ends, and Heather finds him
silently standing in a corner just before
she's attacked herself.
As the film progresses, it becomes clear why
the Blair Witch is never seen: it's simply
far scarier that way.
Based on the 1944 Pulitzer-winning stage play
of the same name by Mary Chase, the 1950 film
Harvey stars James Stewart and Josephine Hull
and tells a rather unconventional tale.
Stewart plays Elwood P. Dowd, a cheerful,
friendly lush with one very unique characteristic:
his best friend is a six-foot-tall, invisible
rabbit named Harvey.
Though Elwood's family, including his sister
and niece, are exasperated and concerned by
Elwood's imaginary friend, his appealingly
pleasant demeanor leads to Elwood making friends
at his neighborhood bar, where the bartender
always greets Harvey and serves Elwood two
martinis.
Naturally, the absence of the film's title
character is what drives the entire story,
as Elwood's family, fearing for his well-being
and sanity, has him committed to an institution
to help potentially "cure" him.
However, over time, Elwood's doctor, Dr. Chumley,
begins to believe Elwood and believe in Harvey.
"At first, Dr. Chumley seemed a little frightened
of Harvey, but that gave way to admiration
as the evening wore on."
In the end, Elwood's loved ones save him from
a medicine that would make him "normal" and
stop him from seeing his beloved bunny bestie.
The film was incredibly well-reviewed, leaving
a lasting lesson that imagination is not a
flaw, but something that can brings real joy
to anyone if they'd only believe.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.